you know when you first started doing
smallville you were kind of like the shy
you were young you were 17 you were do
you still
feel i mean obviously you're more mature
you're a woman now you're doing yeah
obviously but when you go to do these
cons do you get anxious do you get
anxiety do you feel like i can i do this
can i
you know are you are you better around
people because i know you love people
but you're also kind of shy and you know
a little introverted and you're a reader
[Music]
you're a reader we'll get into that but
um yeah so how do you how do you deal
with it um how do you approach it what's
your mentality when you go into
something like that a big convention
well with like the stuff that we do the
actual
scheduled activities
uh the you know signings or the panel or
whatever i really don't find those
things too stressful what i find more
stressful is like our free time sitting
around with all these
um
you know factory types yeah
i don't know
i don't know you guys and i feel really
uncomfortable and i don't know what to
talk to them about so
that's always the most awkward part so
you're saying you're most comfortable
around people and it's the actors and
the that side of it that you're more
uncomfortable with
a little bit i mean i think for me it's
all about
like i know what i need to do
on a panel you know i get asked
there obviously is like i'm not a
performer like you are so
i don't feel like
and i don't even feel pressured to
entertain everybody i just feel like i
just have to answer the questions you
really don't you really don't feel like
pressure to be on you've never felt like
that like i have this
propensity to you know just be on to be
the center of attention to because
because that's all i know and if i don't
do that people will think something's
wrong with me in fact you'll look at me
and go what's wrong with you why are you
quiet no it's true i would assume
something was off
if but i do but do you feel like it's
only a pressure do you like doing that
also i think it's exhausting but i feel
compelled to you know kind of get out of
my skin and just you know be more alive
and be more alive with the people that
give them a show give them something
they'll remember and that's exhausting
for me you know it's always being on
it's always then you get home and you're
like oh my god i just want to die and
everybody's like let's go out for dinner
after i'm like no thanks i feel like
yeah
well i think i think the fans really
appreciate that and i actually i think
tom really appreciates that too it's
like you take a
load off for him i i think
he doesn't he's great at that stuff but
i don't think he wants to carry the
entertainment factor um
so
it's
i mean i think you'll appreciate that
you do it yeah and it would be weird if
you didn't i can't imagine you just
being like
relaxed in a chair just answering
questions
it just doesn't feel like you
maybe the older i get that's what will
happen i'll start to kind of just relax
a little bit and not do that
if you make that decision i will support
you 100 i mean i can't be 70 years old
and beyond can i
you can indeed
and how would you feel about that
see more i'm
wondering what you think i'm worried
about what you'll think as a 70 year old
guy
if it makes you happy
and it it brings you more joy than
stress
then i would support you being on
at 70. if it brings you more stress and
makes your life worse
then i would suggest you just sit calmly
yeah
but you're enjoying you enjoy yourself
when you go there you know what you're
doing now you you know how to talk to
people you're you're a good spirit but
you don't always feel like you have to
be on you're just in a sense you're just
you aren't you i try to be i mean it's a
heightened me obviously i am not i i i
will
i'm i'm a little more mellow generally
um but yeah i'll i i'm mostly just
myself
right but you know before i got into
this i was like welling says hi and we
were both talking and then we got off on
a tangent on
no it was my fault but uh
you